ça peut n'être qu'un passe temps mais
c'est surtout une discipline qui se
pratique en compétition
le tir sportif est le troisième sport
individuel le plus pratiqué dans le
monde et attire des vocations de 7 à
plus de 80 ans jean pierre lui en fait
depuis 40 ans il est le plus ancien
adhérent de ce petit club orléanais et a
participé plus de 30 fois aux
championnats de france
contrairement à ce qu'on imagine de a
priori
le tir est une discipline très physique
c'était aussi le trahit pas votre
physique
vous allez avoir des difficultés en
couple ne serait ce que pour tenir le
temps de la complication
carabine pistolet arbalète en tir
sportif l'objectif est d'atteindre avec
précision et de façon répétitive une
cible située à une distance variable ici
a dit m des règles que connaît bien
cette fratrie chez les level le tir
c'est une histoire de famille
parce que mon frère il en est ainsi du
coup j'ai essayé et ça m'a aussi plu moi
c'est parce que mon frère et ma soeur
est remonté quand je les ai vus tirer
c'est je savais que ça allait me plaire
est un essai j'ai tout de suite bien
aimé moi je sais que je suis le meilleur
vous êtes d'accord
dans notre région le tir sportif connaît
depuis plusieurs années un joli succès
avec plus de 8700 licenciés en 2020 mais
le co vide est passée par là et les
clubs ont dû fermer et puis les jeux
olympiques de tokyo ont débuté le
français jean tic emploi a décroché l'or
et ça ça fait toujours son petit effet
sur la rentrée sportive beaucoup
d'adhésions on a fait une trentaine
nouveaux adhérents quand on a en gagnant
une médaille olympique entend plus quand
c'est une médaille d'or comme ça a été
pareil on clique on poids il ya toujours
un engouement pour le tir l'année qui
suit et cette année les nouveaux
licenciés s'appelle loup robin ou encore
luca ils ont entre 9 et 13 ans et
découvre les règles et les bienfaits de
la discipline plaisir est le fils de
sécurité
c'est comme tu te laisses ta carabine
sur le pas de tir et que tu vas
t'asseoir août a fini ton match tu mets
ce fils pour indiquer que tu as plus de
plomb dans la carabine
élèves qu'ils ici beaucoup pas qui
dérange le court mais calathes et
ailleurs qui a la tête dans la lune et
qu'elle est dans la lune par an et donc
voilà ça m'aide beaucoup à me concentrer
à bien voir le mon objectif et jusqu'au
bout j'aime bien le remplir ses demandes
de la maîtrise il faut faut se maîtriser
les faux et
quelqu'un de très nerveux peut arriver
à se calmer moi j'ai eu un ami à que
quelqu'un a un vrai paquet de nerfs on
l'a remis aux championnats de france
look à 9 ans est lui aussi plutôt agitée
habituellement mais aux tirs sa maman de
le vôtre n'est pas franchement se
débrouille pas mal il fait des bons tirs
des cibles et les atteint donc je suis
agréablement surprise il a une
concentration qui n'a pas forcément dans
la vie de tous les jours et là je le
vois je vois un autre notre petit
bouquin
comme presque tous les pratiquants luca
a découvert le tir dans les fêtes
foraines avant que cela ne devienne une
vraie passion la france compte près de
1700 club de tir dont 83 dans notre
région